hey everyone and welcome back to
Westeros weakly I'm Rianna Galera and
joining me today Patrick Fabian thank
you so much for coming in today
house heaven in the house I really
appreciate it you guys may know Patrick
as Howard Hamlin on better call Saul but
I know him as a game of Thrones super
fan love it love it love it
appointment TV and I love last night's
episode I heard that sound was so good
we're going to be breaking down
everything you need to remember from the
Queen's Justice because you know they
say a Lannister always pays their debts
but apparently the tyrell is get the
last word whoo
plus we have exclusive quotes from
Nikolaj coster-waldau talking about the
biggest game of Thrones theory out there
what's that stay tuned thanks for
talking about it but let's jump right
into the Nights Watch we have to talk
about the biggest moment of the night in
my opinion which was the fact that
you're on came and brought those legal
gifts for Cersei yeah he did he did but
you know what I think he was showboating
a little too much a little too much
walking through the crowd like just
waving like he is like the ish well the
thing is it's not his throne room I mean
he thinks it is she's acting like it is
but it's not his yet and so this sort of
waltz in there the way he did I get it
the fact that Cersei sort of sat there
and didn't tip her hat about what she
felt about him taking over the throne
and once again shows that she really has
the power anyway well and also I loved
that he had said like you know this was
my hopeful engagement gift for you and
she shut him down and she's like yeah
after the war honey boy typical right by
me never take me to a movie yeah what
did you think of your ons like side jab
to Jaime again I weirdly I somehow the
Kingslayer I have an affection for yeah
we lost his hand he's trying his best in
a really bad situation and I don't think
he has he's earned the right to go ahead
and jab him like that publicly so I you
know who doesn't want to see him get his
throat you know slam sometimes I I don't
think that you're I think you're right I
really don't think that you're on have
earned the right to act like this big of
a bad guy which is why I think he's
getting set up for a fall although so
far everything seems to be cutting his
way speaking of cutting moment
Cersei getting her revenge oh my gosh
when
sat down ilaria and laid out her master
plan of how she was going to get her
revenge on the fact that she killed
Marcela what was your thought when
you're watching the scene first of all I
didn't see it coming and then when it
got executed pardon the pun I thought oh
of course that's the way you do it
because don't crack or don't crack your
head open like a nut you can't do that's
too quick yeah
so what's long and slow but but what's
the torture and the exquisite torture is
putting her in the same position that
she was put in we actually have that
clip so let's take a look
[Music]
those will die here and myself you will
be here watching what she does in the
air the rest of your days you refuse to
eat the full suit down your throat you
will miss to watch your daughter on that
beautiful face collapsible member all
the while contemplating the choices
you've made
ah whether you love her or hate her you
have to commend Cersei for her vicious
ways of torture absolutely and you know
what it almost looks like it pains her
as much as it pains the people who are
going to die which is kind of amazing
you think it pains her I think she gets
her rocks off on it as we saw in the
next round
yeah talk about a full-service surfing
this week right oh my god there's a
turn-on and the I forget a glass of wine
let's just torture mother and daughter
for a little bit but also I love how
Jamie said no no one can see it's like
this and she's like I'm the queen I do
not care anymore
excuse me we need fresh sheets in the
bedroom okay speaking of another awkward
moment okay well we got a happy moment
first was that a stark family reunion
yeah yeah first one was gonna be Aria
you think well I first had that re I had
made it all the way back to the north
like she's got like the I don't know the
rest way yeah she took the train you
know I don't know so I was sort of I
forgot Braun was like right there at the
watch right yeah so he came down we got
a really sweet hug between them it was
really great yeah but when he and swans
are we talking and she's trying to
understand these three eyed Raven
abilities yeah and he just comes in with
a crazy mind repeating
okay let's relive this and then we're
going to dissect it let's do the quick
run I'm sorry for all that happened T
I'm sorry it had to happen here in our
home
episode beautiful that night snow for
just like now
and you were so beautiful and your white
wedding dress
absolutely sidebar Oh stamp it longer
yeah you say a little bit longer
think about what you just need to stay
out there like you could have said
anything through your hair nice you
gained some weight correlations you're
sending out it was so cool to see you
take Winterfell back or like that army
was amazing but no let's talk about the
night but you got it
happy wedding but here's the thing may
you know in case you lead with I'm going
to distance you from me as quickly as
possible yeah lay down the new rules of
the land I am NOT the guy you used to
know yeah I am not part of your world
I don't want Winterfell I'm not looking
to take it from you or John but it was
so creepy it was really creepy creepy uh
something that surprised me last night
your auras grayscale is gone how about
that all you to do was actually just
took a needle in there and rip it off
but and then that and then rub some
ointment on it and you're good you're
fine maybe it was Vaseline I don't even
know he was mixed vapor rub sites going
a little bit was that that's how they
cured it that's all you had to do Sam
was probably looking through the books
on like a grayscale oh rip the skin off
and put some salve on I can do that
that's fine and I love how the grand
maesters like how did you do it was like
I read the book a faulty instruction and
that was it
good good John let's go to the island
and kill them all exactly we actually
have a clip of their interaction
Daenerys Stormborn convinced me
otherwise in the place for me is back
with her I love my life thank you and
just like that you live in the Citadel
Khaleesi
here I come I know I hope that they
actually reunite because she said like
you can't come back unless you get it
curious I mean she actually said go
carry yourself she thought that there's
no way in hell he's gonna do that bye
thank you so much for all these days I
can't wait to see her face when he
knocks in the door
hey it's me I did what you said and
she's like oh snap I need to like clear
some room in my advisory board to like
welcome you back in there can we get
another chair in here Paige orifice but
you know Danny sent her unsullied are me
to go take Casterly Rock
and they realize that none of the
Lannisters were actually home terrible
can at first I was like oh it's a whole
Trojan horse thing I love the speech
that Tyrion gives about saying like you
know my father gave me the terrible job
and I made a terrible job good for me
it's going to help me now I'm going to
be great it's going to really be cool
instead it's not cool at all and instead
we found out that Jaime sent all of the
Lannister army to Highgarden to surprise
attack the tyrell absolutely although I
will say Jaime on horseback is a
refreshing sight to see again no wasn't
it horseback in a while so it's good to
see him also I love that Bronn his
right-hand man just right beside him oh
I love bronze he's great on but so they
go and they take Highgarden and he sits
down with Elena Elena who always who
seemingly is waiting to accept whatever
fate is given her yes but also like
still be in charge I love the line that
we were talking about when she says like
how did we fare like how did good Tyrell
are we doing okay and he's like yeah you
did okay she's like well we are golden
roses what yeah we're not really know
about firefighting remembers for our
money and then he said you know I
negotiated a dignified death for you
which immediately makes me go having
just watched Cersei give somebody else a
destiny what did she have in store for
lady Tyrell that's what I want to know
he wanted to run her through the same
planning she wanted to fillet her alive
she wanted to behead her in front of
everyone but Jamie's like I actually
just got you some really sweet poison
how about that the Lannisters are nice
yeah Jaime's nice kids are just some
really sweet poison she asked us that'll
hurt and did no I made sure of it puts
in a nice Cabernet yeah it's way to go
have a nice way to go you got any last
words lady Tyrell I mean I think that we
need to give the award for the I see a
moment of the nine to the one the only
the most badass grandma in Westeros only
a Tyrell listen to what she said okay
I'd hate to die like you son
clawing at my neck foam and bile
spilling from my mouth eyes blood red
skin purple must been horrible for you
as a Kingsguard the father
it was horrible enough for me a shocking
scene not at all what I intended do you
see I'd never seen the poison work
before
Oh Scottie
I wanted to tell you so good from beyond
a point of the ayats sir see here's my
question for you Patrick do you think
Jamie will actually tell Cersei
I think it's provided Jamie with a
weapon in his toolbox if Cersei crosses
him or hurts him exactly well because
obviously like certainly didn't react to
Tommen's death she didn't really process
it wast compartmentalize and it's like
when Joffrey died she was hell-bent on
getting revenge on Joffrey's death when
Marcella died she just now got revenge
she doesn't necessarily need revenge on
Tommen other than it was that it was the
Tyrells deaths that men like they're
still to blame without a deputies right
she hasn't processed it yet Jamie brings
up this information it will open up a
whole well of awfulness there's no way
for her to get revenge because they've
killed all the terror no so you're going
to deliver that you better deliver it
from a distance yeah moving into keeping
up with Khaleesi
coming soon we're going up with our
favorite mother of dragons this week
because it was the epic showdown we've
been waiting for this forever her and
John King in the north thank the mother
of dragons who just want to see that
finally meeting what did you think of
their initial reaction to each other
well you know I have to say I was in
Davos as camp you know after all this -
stuff and she's sitting on the throne
and welcoming him you know she does need
him and that whole it felt like it felt
like the two kids in the family could
actually sit down at a can we just talk
instead she acted like you know like the
fathers and the mothers yeah so Jon
standing there weaponless with just
Davos on his side I loved Davos say like
um mrs. Jon Snow the King on anything
else anything else we need to know so I
didn't get go I didn't think it went
well for her I know she looked like she
was wearing a part that she doesn't wear
very well I think that she has stepped
into the uber regal realm this year and
and while she is acting very clean line
she is acting a little bit like her
father's daughter sometimes I think she
was better when she was on the road
making it up as she went along seriously
seriously um well we'll be getting to
this in a little bit I was going to
quote something from the teaser trailer
but patrick hasn't watched it so he
doesn't like to watch any of the teaser
ever
but I'll do it today but we did get to
see that you know Tyrion was talking
with John and kind of convinced him to
kind of you know
appeal to Danny's better side that they
both need something from each other well
you know Tyrion also was reminding him
one that he looks really good standing
up on a cliff and he does with no Jon
Snow is good in profile good secondly
that you know even though he's a king
he's still a young he's a young guy
right and so he's making a young guy
mistake it's two egos in the throne room
and Tyrion is there as the hand of the
king is really supposed to be there
ahead of the Queen to go ahead and be
like right right right you can go ahead
and left that but what you really ought
to think about is this and think about
that and think about that so so the boy
king can go ahead and go oh maybe I'll
do this now I do think it was
interesting that he kept they kept
referring to hit John as king of the
north but Danny kept saying like I'm
Mickey warden of the north
right is that it does that feel like a
step up or step down down drag king is
king but she was gonna allow the Greyjoy
daughter to be the queen yeah yeah yeah
yeah so you know it's funny so she only
like is really ladies that she's going
to go ahead and give a royalty to I mean
a warden that sounds like he's like a
like a park ranger and Alaska Park
Rangers but we did eventually see that
they reached a little bit of a of a
mutual understand I wanted more though
don't you want more I want more okay
let's watch the screen I will allow you
to mine the dragon glass and forge
weapons from it any resources or men you
needa will provide for you
thank you
so you believe me then how about the
night king in the army of the Dead
you better get to work John Stehr
paginating she believes him not a bit
did you see her braids she's spending
all day making her hair looking good
she's not worried look really great it's
particularly good well you know and that
goes in the idea like she's become more
regal yeah and a little more stiff both
in the way that she acts and talked it's
almost like she's trying on something
that doesn't quite fit her exactly and
per here for this scene I think I was I
was missing either a line or an exchange
or maybe a scene before the scene yeah
because all of a sudden she's like yeah
go ahead and mind the Dragonstone and
all that I'm not sure why the give came
so easily we did had the scene between
her and Tyrion where he was explaining
to her like look I still vouch for this
guy like Japan had the dragon glass it
doesn't like matter to you so but I did
think that it was a little abrupt yeah I
you know what maybe just because we want
to see a little more strings and sparks
exact moment Ryan sex is what we are in
romantic about I was expecting to see it
a little bit more sparks it was
interesting to me that they did not
quite hit it off well maybe guess what
they don't hit it off right now but
later on do you think that that's okay
even though she's his aunt I hear
wedding bells let's move on to something
that I'm really excited about every week
we catch up with one of your favorite
game of Thrones stars or celebs 2 / fans
to do our wildfire Fast Five alright
Patrick
5 questions answering as quickly as you
can Ready Set who's your favorite
character and why Littlefinger because
he's going to live isn't a [ __ ] right
she just won't die don't call that if
you could bring back one character back
to life who would it be Oh Catherine
start don't we all love her love her who
do you think won't make it out alive
this season Spyder really yeah
interesting yeah yeah I think it's gonna
come from left field but I think he's
gonna be gone okay which unlikely
team-up would you like to see before the
series end oh you know what is it
possible is it possible to John Snow and
Cersei actually somehow form an alliance
is it possible is it possible my mind
right now White Walkers are big lastly
who do you think will be on the Iron
Throne before the end of the season I
hope I hope that Arya Stark is you think
that's a long jump there's a long job
but you know what did you see how fast
they got from
the wall down to Dragonstone like that
we were talking about the fact that like
we have no idea what the timeline is at
this point because John got to
Dragonstone real quick
but re-instill somewhere in the middle
of the woods and so either they had
really bad Matt but they just going to
forget which way they're going every now
and then or that Aria decided not to
actually go back to Winterfell and she's
going to continue with her plan of keep
killing me look who's plotting ahead I
think and that's it but we are going to
take a look right now at the race to the
iron throne and we check in with our
main players so Cersei crushed it this
week sure did she's still on the throne
she's eliminating all of her enemies
poor Danny last place this week yeah it
was funny you had three dragons in 3rd
place that doesn't make sense but you
know what she's a comer and they say the
horse-racing but also it was just so
interesting that last week we saw that
she had made all this progress with all
those women and they're all pretty much
dead at this point what a bummer what a
difference a week makes yeah in Westeros
and John did make a little bit of
progress in terms of getting his
dragonglass
sure I though here's a question for you
yeah how long does it take to mind
dragonglass into weapons that's what I'd
like to know yeah and also are they
going to be making the weapons their
dragons are they're just going to be
taking it back with them and then making
the weapons up at the north maybe maybe
a little hand grenade dragon glasses
maybe a little slivers how much dragons
a stuff do you need exactly call Sam
there is to know yeah seriously though I
do want Sam to come back but yeah ah
we'll see well this is where we're going
to keep talking about all of our series
because there is one theory out there
that I'm so excited about and we
actually caught up with Nikolaj
coster-waldau about it and let me just
paint you a little picture project
already so you know Circe's prophecy yes
now he predicted that all three of her
children would die and she ended the
prophecy with when your tears have
drowned you the valonqar shall wrap his
hands around your pale white throat and
choke the life out of you oh wait wait
what's the the V word what's a Down car
which is high Valyrian for little
brother now naturally you would sing to
Tyrion sure but Circe's older than Jaime
by about five minutes so it could Jamie
who turned on Cersei
so I actually caught up with Nikolaj ass
the thrones premier and talk to him
about the theory and watch how he
stumbles through his response it's a
valid theory I I you know I can I can
only imagine would be a very very
specific and very extreme circumstances
I would wear in why I could even be a
possibility I had but who knows oh he's
totally put on the spot who knows who
knows I can rerun that into the court
please I really think that that would be
the case you know that'd be great but
okay then we learn to show is it a
one-handed strangle okay or is it a
awarded a one-handed golden strangle
that sounds very silly could he actually
work or like me very tender and the
other water okay so he could do it yes
or or he could just take the hand off
and just beat her oh not by the prophecy
is strangling the image of Tyrion being
up at her throat with his legs at her
knees that certainly is good maybe have
to be in water you know what I don't
know I can see this lad right it seems
like a 50-50 it's a coin toss there are
other theories out there that still
think that it could be Jon Snow
but I don't think that that I still
don't think of Jon Snow as a killer yeah
I really I don't think of it in his in
his heart although he did say this
episode he goes I know what I am and I
think he didn't Plaza he's a killer but
I don't think he is again that profile
is it's a easy key Bono
he's a lead singer do you need to talk
about the fact that Jon Snow made sure
to go when he mentioned well met he's
kind of talked about a zombie right now
it's your real he's kind of a
resurrected guilt you bring up
resurrection at dinner it becomes a very
awkward conversation you had to help
offended they have to believe it you
have to excuse yourself a go to the
bathroom yeah I love how Jamie's like
good he was stopped in the heart she
didn't catch it and and Tyrion you know
it quickly is like uh did he say that
yeah I didn't I don't know anyway said
what's for lunch yeah so Lucy um so much
happened in this week's episode but
we're going to talk about next week's
episode
Patrick's about to watch the teaser for
the very first time
I only venture at this moment citria
establishing control over this continent
and every person on it
my allies are gone I'm living you can
count on the iron back as soon as the
gold about enough with the clever plan
and not the clever plans Wow I think
she's being dismissive to Tyrion on that
one right you think she's going to take
Elena Terrell's advice to gross ignore
Tyrion oh man if she oh if she does that
puts him out of a job
I know but it may bring some dragon
stuff involves right okay here's the
thing all of their plans were so clever
and it was so great and I was so excited
about like you know the Casterly Rock
and coming in and working inside but
none of their cleverness is paid off at
this point she might just have to accept
the fact that she needs to tell a couple
thousand people to grab a crown you must
use brute force look great I did it with
this fleet brought them all back I mean
so there is something to be said that
brute force sometimes winning isn't
brutish brutish land we live in called
Westeros here's my question for you do
you think that one of Danny's dragons is
going to die by the end of the season I
do only because they showed that that uh
that giant crossbow into the skull of
the giant dragons and I thought you
don't you don't make that you don't show
us that if it's not going to put
somebody down and she's got three
dragons so she's got one to spare don't
you think I don't think she has one to
spare that's outside no offense to the
dragon my advice to Danny's dragons
please don't be like Rick on big zag
please there you go
do not run in a straight line there's no
of course he died they'll catch you
commenting dragons serpentine serpentine
fire bomb I think I could talk about
Game of Thrones with you all day but we
are out of time right now
Thank You Grammy thank you so much for
stopping by it was such a delight and
thank you all guys for watching right
now be sure to subscribe to
entertainment tonight's YouTube channel
and be sure to LIKE this video if you
had fun keep it lost to ichi online for
all your Game of Thrones news thanks so
much I'm Liana Guerra this is Patrick
Fabian we'll see you next time bye